I just want you to ponder the
strangeness of what we're about to do
right okay when we started this
conversation over here what does this
have to do with complex numbers well
nothing really like angles are all real
numbers right it's like oh um this far
or that far we don't really have any
category for what it would mean to have
a complex angle but just because and
essentially when people ask this and in
fact I'll tell your story later well you
know some of you saw me yesterday
walking around I was wearing suit um
well just the jacket really anyway the
reason why I was wearing suit is because
I was going to this summit in the city
and I was gonna meet lots of people
waiting students oh yeah absolutely
now what happened was I it was a summit
about like STEM science technology
engineering maths which I kind of know a
little bit about right and there are all
these important people in industry like
Rio Tinto and BHP Billiton people who
really want people who have STEM skills
universities politicians even etc right
there's one man there who I don't know
if you know his name his name who he is
his name is Adrian piccoli he's the
state minister for education so he looks
after the budget and makes decisions
about for example you know what kinds of
what kinds of people can become teachers
and what kind of tertiary qualifications
they require in New South Wales okay now
to my surprise he got up and he he was
hosting in the event and I'm he did the
first like five minute opening remarks
and that kind of thing and I've been in
before and he actually asked me on the
spot he just put me on the spot he said
why do people like I'm not I'm not
making them I didn't prepare this
beforehand he said why do people why do
mathematicians care about the square
root of negative one like that was just
his question to me like just over dinner
it's like hey you know it has the right
I have the kids why do people care about
complex numbers right so I was just on
the spot I have ten seconds to think of
an answer okay now what everyone wants
is an answer which is like they're a
part of the world okay and by the way
these do exist they're part of the world
that cannot be expressed
apart from complex numbers now by the
way that's true okay we know that
complex numbers they introduce
this idea of doing mathematics of spin
that rotation write anything that spins
and rotates can be expressed most
powerfully through complex numbers right
you know important things like say
planets and stars and the supermassive
black hole that everything in our galaxy
is orbiting and subatomic particles and
all of those things because they spin
complex numbers is what's going to take
over when the mathematics is trying to
understand it right but the same time
you get things like this which you do
not need any complex numbers to explore
this right which is why 95% of students
will explore this without ever ever
referring to these things but despite
the fact that all of that's in real
numbers right the complex numbers give
us a door in there like an extra tool
that you have that it's like well I
don't need this tool to approach this
this area or to understand this but when
you use it it's just like wow the
insights that you get right so let me
kind of demonstrate them to you okay
let's think about this guy let's think
about this guy I want to purchase this
result and at the same time
in fact because it's complex numbers I
have to do it at the same time I'm not
just gonna figure out sign through here
I'm gonna think about cos 3 theta ok so
he's the way we're going to do it I want
you to consider okay I wanna consider
any arbitrary complex number raised to
the third power okay now you can see why
I'm raising it to third power
because what I'm interesting is that
when you triple an angle and when you
multiply a complex number by itself
three times based on the arithmetic of
complex numbers what you give the angle
you you add the ankle three times
multiplying the complex number three
times means you add the angle three
times okay so I want to consider this
guy right first we're gonna do a third
more like the elegant way that we know
it let's do it by do Marsden that's just
like one line let's just quickly state
it right what is this what's it going to
be remember it's in my life already and
according to this looks like the module
suit
one just state it for me what is
democracy and tell us that is cos 3
theta plus yep good okay you happy with
that
like that's understating that by
tomorrow but you remember how much
mathematicians love to take an object
and approach it from multiple angles
every time you do that you should get
the same result but it looks different
which means that there should be some
comparison you can make so I can I can
deal with this by tomorrow's theorem but
because it's a have a look at it every
complex number every complex number is a
binomial is it not it's a pair of things
right and two pair of things that cannot
mix this real and this imaginary so I
have a binomial and I'm raising it to
the third power right so everything that
we've learnt already in binomial theorem
I can use to expand this guy right so
let's now think about here from the
viewpoint of a binomial expansion okay
excuse me
I've only chosen the power 3 so the
coefficients are the four coefficients n
again from Pascal's triangle are going
to be 1 3 3 and 1 okay so let's just
slowly go through this what I'm going to
get is this is that first term okay so
I've got cos cube theta right plus what
I've got my coefficient 1 3 3 1 so now
I'm up to my 3
I've got cos squared sine squared but
I'm missing I'm missing I've got to have
one lot of I in with that sine theta
right you agree with that so I'm going
to just put him at the end here okay
just because I want to identify in a
second which of the real and imaginary
parts okay 1 3 what's the next 3
everything's positive I'll have no
negatives yet
okay you're maybe evaluating the I
already I'm not quite there yet I'm
gonna have one letter cause I'm gonna
have sine squared and then how many eyes
we're gonna have yeah I squared just
hanging out there on the end and then my
last step I've got one three three I'm
back to one
what do I get to be it's gonna be sine
cubed and how many eyes do I have three
of them okay now excuse me
remember I said this is the same object
the same object right so this and this
are equivalent right they are in fact
they're equal right it's just a pressure
from - English questions okay so now as
I continue over here I can now separate
out my real and imaginary parts okay in
another color real this is gonna be real
right and then you've got the color
imaginary imaginary you okay with that
so let's tighten this thing up and Mulan
will separate them out nice and
obviously I'm gonna have cars huge feet
are that's gonna kill - right - now
while I'm at it okay I see that this is
sine squared right
I'm just gonna rewrite as 1 minus cos
squared you can probably look forward
and see why I'm doing that okay close
bracket real part done right what's the
imaginary part
run that guy at the front right because
I've already done it in an earlier
question I'm going to write that cos
square as 1 minus sine 3 sine theta and
then here I've taken out one of the eyes
which leaves two of them there which
become negative one minus sine cubed
happy with that
yes okay let's just tidy this up ever so
little okay I've got cos cubed I've got
one of them there and then I'm gonna
take away three there B minus 3 cos
theta that will just sit by itself but
there will also be plus 3 cos cube did
you see that double negative because cos
you're happy with that so I've got one
cost cutie and then I'm gonna have three
more which leaves me with four of them
at the front take away 3 cos theta happy
that yes
plus I all right now when you have a
look at this if I hold on I just did
this denied tonight
it was just right there okay so you can
you can go ahead and redo it just like I
did here or you can you can verify you
know it's just gonna be this okay
doesn't it doesn't take that long to
verify there you go three times 1 times
sine theta tada right 3 times negative
sine squared times sine gives you minus
3 sine cubed and is already a sine cube
there - thank you thank you all right
yeah
oh okay now here comes the hard right
remember I was looking the same object
and I expanded it into eggs or not
extended i reworked it I restated it I
represented it in two different ways but
this still the same object so over here
on the Left I also have a real and
imaginary part cos 3 theta plus I sine
theta right so just like I've been doing
I can equate the real and imaginary
parts and bam I have already my two
expansions I've already stated beside
13:1 there it is there right I might as
well just totally say it
equating real imaginary parts okay the
real pot is cluster etheta on the left
and it's full closed cute speed-up minus
3 cos theta on the right and I already
know what the sine one is okay just like
that